[Musique]
originaire d'Indonésie le tempeh tout
comme le tofu est une protéine végétale
la différence c'est qu'il est faite à
base de fèves de soya fermenté comme on
le fait ici dans cette usine de Montréal
et vous allez avoir le privilège
de voir sous vos yeux comment ça se fait
c'est sûr
qui est déjà cassé
nettoyer là on vient de laver peser
laver et là on fait la cuisson on
démarre notre minuterie et à la
mi-cuisson on va ajouter du vinaigre
une fois cuit et refroidie le soya sera
inoculé par un champignon afin d'être
fermenté c'est un champignon on ajoute
dans le soya pour vraiment permettre à
ce que ça se ferme on va dans la salle
de ferme
c'est là qu'on assiste au miracles des
fèves de soya bouillies qui vont se
transformer tranquillement pour devenir
un bloc de gâteau tout blanc on fait une
fermentation lente au lieu de faire un
24 heures on fait en 48 heures cette
fermentation en lente adoucit un peu le
goût du temple
[Musique]
on obtient une galette de grains de soya
à la texture à la fois ferme et souple
au début ça n'allait Jasmine ne
connaissait pas le tempe
je connaissais pas toute la et puis
c'est quand mon fils voulait pas manger
de la viande il est arrivé il y avait
huit ans il y a des moments pas pour
votre information là je veux plus manger
de la viande ok un ami nous a parlé du
tempe
je sais même pas c'est quoi personne a
aimé ça honnêtement est-ce que c'est moi
qui l'ai comme mal apprêté
[Musique]
c'est dans sa cuisine que Jasmine a
commencé à faire des tests par essaie et
erreur elle a créé et développer un
tempé mariné assaisonné et prête à
manger ils ont eu l'idée de le
commercialiser tantine henné
ça c'est le haché qu'on a ici et ici on
a les burgers qui sont en train d'être
refroidis parce que ça a été pasteurisé
récemment c'est bon pour le microbiote
et les nutritionnistes peuvent vous en
dire plus long là-dessus mais ce conseil
c'est une très bonne chose de protéines
végétales qui est à être connu un peu
plus vu que c'est fermenté ça a un goût
particulier quand il s'est fait formater
des fois ça a un goût de noisette
certaines personnes disent c'est la
patate nos deux c'est chaque personne
attribue un goût à ça mais l'idée
l'essentiel c'est que quand on les
compare avec les autres à protéines à
base plante le tempe siège en haut je
pense qu'il y a d'autres personnes qui
avaient ce même frein que moi
qui dit bon laisse tomber ce produit là
on va pas l'aimer pour toute la c'est
pas si bon je dis bien je vais le
partager avec le Québec pourquoi pas et
c'est là c'est arrivé on a vu qu'il y a
vraiment un potentiel d'affaires
là-dedans on a trouvé quelque chose pour
la famille pour mon fils et là on le
partage avec tout le monde
en épicerie on trouve différentes
marques de Tempe qui soit nature ou
encore prête à manger déjà assaisonner
nous avons demandé à la nutritionniste
Karine Lamoureux d'analyser cette offre
vraiment c'est impressionnant plusieurs
marques puis on a quand même des saveurs
vraiment intéressantes on parle de 1% de
sodium un pourcent de sucre vraiment
très très léger donc ça je suis
impressionné beaucoup de fibres on parle
de une boulette ça nous donne 25% de nos
fibres de la journée est-ce qu'on a pas
du tout dans une boulette de steak haché
là donc vraiment intéressant
le tempe permet de varier d'ajouter
différents nutriments à notre
alimentation
la première différence dans le temp
c'est que ça va contenir la five entière
donc ils vont encore avoir les fibres
chose qu'on a plus dans le tofu le
deuxième avantage et au niveau de la
fermentation pour le thème P le
champignon qui est habituellement
utilisé le réseau puce oligosporus c'est
vraiment bénéfique par exemple au niveau
des bactéries intestinales l'autre
avantage c'est que ça va aider à briser
les protéines et les glucides complexes
qu'on a dans la légumineuse donc ça va
favoriser l'absorption
un substitué à la viande qui une fois
transformé peut parfois contenir de
grandes quantités de sodium un critère à
considéré pour mieux choisir selon la
nutritionniste pour une personne une
portion d'à peu près 100 g idéalement on
voudrait pas dépasser 20% de sodium ici
on a pour quatre lanières de tempé
on a 680 mg de sodium on parle de 28% de
sodium c'est sûr que si on compare avec
du véhicule on s'entend que c'est
vraiment meilleur choix comme le tofu a
pris beaucoup de temps dans le passé
pour se faire accepter mais le tempe son
temps aussi mais qu'est-ce qui arrive
c'était le frein de hack le goût comme
amertume qui existe c'est certain que le
temple il faut un peu larivoiser donc
c'est pas tout le monde qui aime ça on
peut le faire bouillir ça ça peut
diminuer un petit peu le goût que
certaines personnes vont moins aimer on
l'utilise ensuite dans nos recettes on
peut le mariner la saisonner et le
griller quand on fait cuire le tempeh on
change sa saveur donc on va on va avoir
des saveurs de caramel qui vont être
plus accentués qui va donner ce goût là
particulier qui va se rapprocher de la
viande grillée aussi
[Musique]
Martel amoureux et professeur en chimie
alimentaire et consultant pour sonner la
semaine depuis le tout début
le temph à la demande du couple le
burger et le cube il génère ce qu'on
appelle des rébus parce qu'on les coupe
et il y a des retraites que en règle
générale on devait jeter on a jeté dans
le passé on s'est dit on va faire
quelque chose qui va ressembler à un
steak haché
le tempi s'intègre à différents plats
Jasmine propose d'en faire une sauce à
spaghetti elle fait des brochettes ou
l'ajoute dans un sauté de légumes ça
serait vraiment les protéines végétales
notre choix numéro 1 avant même le
poisson on parle d'un minimum de trois
repas par semaine quand on parle de
protéines végétales on inclut les
légumineuses on inclut le tofu le
s'étend le tempe et toutes les autres
protéines à base de légumineuses c'est
important pour le climat pour
l'environnement pour nos enfants pour
bien être animal et pour tout mais
au-delà de ça mais pour notre santé on a
dit si nous on n'a pas aimé au début là
c'était comme un non catégorie pour nous
et on arrive à un point où on peut le
manger pourquoi ne pas le partager avec
ce Quebec là qui nous a accueilli
[Musique]